pas de déconfinement total le président
l'a affirmé dans le journal du dimanche
il faut de la cohérence de la clarté un
cap
il s'agira d'un assouplissement des
règles du confinement
le chef de l'état prendra de nouveau la
parole ce mardi
objectif annoncé les mesures
d'allégement du confinement
alors que le pic de la seconde vague
semble avoir été franchi même si les
indicateurs restent à des niveaux élevés
leurs observations suggèrent que le pic
épidémique de la seconde vague a été
franchi quelles pourraient être ces
nouvelles mesures pour les petits
commerces
actuellement à l'étude auprès du haut
conseil de la santé publique
le nouveau protocole permettrait une
réouverture sous conditions diviser par
deux le nombre de personnes présentes en
magasin avec au minimum une personne
pour huit mètres carrés de surface
contre 4 mètres carrés avant leur
confinement dans les salons de coiffure
où les concessions automobiles
les commerçants seront invités à
travailler sur rendez vous sans rendre
la mesure obligatoire des consultations
seront également ouvertes concernant le
travail dominical et les horaires
élargis le black friday menacé de
boycott par de nombreux groupes de
commerçants et décalée d'une semaine et
aura lieu le 4 décembre
une petite victoire à l'issue d'un
combat mené contre les grands acteurs du
commerce comme amazon carrefour ou
encore leclerc par le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire sous réserve
je cite d'une réouverture des commerces
d'ici là pour les restaurants et les
bars les réouvertures reste incertaine
pour les attestations du déplacement
elle devrait être maintenue avec les
neuf motifs connu actuellement activité
professionnelle achats consultations et
soins motif familial impérieux situation
de handicap convocations judiciaires ou
administratives missions d'intérêt
général enfants à l'école déplacement
bref avec un bémol sur le maintien du
déplacement brède
un rayon maximum d'1 km sur lequel le
gouvernement ne s'est pas encore exprimé
autre interrogation le retour du couvre
feu qui avait été évoquée par un conseil
scientifique le 26 octobre dernier une
mesure qui viserait à limiter les effets
de la pandémie sans sanctionner les
activités économiques et sociales
cette période de confinement pourrait
être suivie par une période de
couvre-feu sanitaire qui préserverait
davantage qu'à confinement certaines
activités économiques et sociales
limitant d'autant les effets délétères
de l'épidémie un couvre feu qui aurait
réellement eu un effet bénéfique selon
santé publique france - 40% de
contaminer -13% d'hospitalisation -9%
admission en réanimation dans la semaine
du 9 au 15 novembre dans toute la france
dans une même démarche de prévention dès
lundi des tests antigénique seront mises
en place dans une trentaine de lycées
d'ile-de-france pour les personnels
volontaires et les élèves qui avaient
fortement manifesté ces dernières
semaines des mesures que le gouvernement
compte fermement appliquée dans le
contexte de la lutte sans relâche contre
le virus le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations par jour diminue
régulièrement depuis de ce bel pour
autant ne faut pas baisser la garde
il faut maintenir nos efforts puisque
relâcher les efforts aujourd'hui ce
serait les avoir fait pour rien ou quant
aux déplacements des français pendant
les fêtes de fin d'année les billets de
train sont réservables dès maintenant et
remboursable la sncf ayant prévu de
faire circuler tous ses trains du 15
décembre au 4 janvier
dans l'attenté d'une confirmation du
gouvernement rendez vous donc mardi soir